we went Hands-On with Star Wars Jedi
Survivor and learned a ton of new
information about the game while there
are still a lot of things we can't talk
about one thing we can reveal is that
the story will tie into threads around
the high Republic first unveiled in 2020
via a multimedia project of comics
novels and web series The High Republic
is a 300 year period that ends roughly
50 years before the events of The
Phantom Menace it's essentially the
Republic's golden age and very new to
the Star Wars Canon it hasn't been
explored much outside of comics and a
handful of books for those worried that
the playable Jedi calcast would be
lacking the abilities and lightsaber
forms he learned by the end of Fallen
order at the start of Survivor I have
some good news Cal will retain those
abilities as well as the option to
utilize a dual-sided lightsaber from the
jump and only new abilities and weapon
options will be locked behind
progression the customization options
for Cal as well as his Droid companion
have been greatly increased no longer
will bd1 have to settle for a simple
different colorway but can have its
parts switched out giving it a totally
different look for cal gone are the
ponchos of Fallen Aura thank God in
favor of a much wider variety of
clothing choices as well as options to
change his facial hair and hairstyle you
can even give him a blast from the past
or future relative to Star Wars with a
flotastic mullet a haircut that may or
may not be back in Vogue today depending
on who you ask for more information
check out our full video preview of the
game right here on Gamespot mullets
might be back in and that's no April
fools something you can also say but
asus's Rog Ally the new handheld PC from
the Computing manufacturer after
initially posting what many consider to
be a prank trailer for the device on
April 1st Asus has since gone on to
confirm that the Ally is indeed a real
product the handheld will run a custom
chip from AMD inside and YouTuber David
2D suggests that it utilizes a Zen 4
plus rdna3 Apu price and availability
haven't been revealed though Best Buy
has a listing up for it but no pre-order
option just yet the device can also be
plugged into the Rog XG mobile egpu
which not only acts as a charging dock
to connect to a TV over HDMI but will
give your device a little extra
graphical capability when playing on a
bigger higher resolution screen the
YouTube Linus Tech tips found that they
could actually game in 4k at high
settings on a TV when plugged in with
this external GPU option keep an eye on
gamespot.com for more details on the
device such as full specs price and
release date when that information
becomes available if the only handheld
gaming you're doing or plan to be doing
in the near future is on the Nintendo
switch you might run run into issues
with joy-con drift a problem that has
plagued the device since launch while
stick drift isn't a problem exclusive to
joy-cons it does seem to be a much
bigger problem than with other
controllers in fact a UK consumer Group
found that two in five joy-con
controllers developed drift as such to
dodge any legal trouble in the
historically more consumer-friendly
European Union Nintendo will now repair
broken or faulty joy-cons for free in a
large number of countries in that region
even if your joy cons are out of
warranty sorry Americans you'll have to
fix your joy-con drift woes the good
old-fashioned way capitalism intended by
buying new ones are you excited by those
new details regarding Jedi survivor's
story and gameplay are you interested in
the Rog Ally let us know in the comments
below and we will see you here for more
Gamespot news
[Music]
thank you